[Music]
foreign it's been more than three years
since Bradley Cooper and arena shake
called it quits but the exes were just
photographed with their arms wrapped
around one another and a source tells
E.T there's still a lot of love between
them family is everything that's Bradley
and Arena walking their dogs in New York
City on Tuesday getting nice and close
the Oscar nominee keeping it cash
rocking Shades a t-shirt a blue jacket
matching pants and shoes while the model
kept it low-key too in a chic white tea
long coat jeans and black loafers just
simple less is more that's what is my
style and comfortable the cozied up
outing is just the latest in a string of
sightings of the former couple whose
breakup made headlines in 2019 after
four years of dating but despite their
split a source tells ET that the two are
friendly as the they continue to raise
their five-year-old daughter Leah a
source tells E.T Bradley and Arena are
great co-parents and love spending time
together as a family and on their own in
fact back in 2021 Arena showed Bradley
her support at the premiere of his flick
nightmare alley we were very happy to
see your family Arena here celebrating
you tonight it's very special yeah and
in August Arena shared this snap from
what appeared to be a joint vacay happy
happy grateful
ET sour says they have a good thing
going and still have a lot of love for
one another it's very surreal quote they
have so much fun together whether
they're just hanging out vacationing or
going out the connection and flirty Vibe
between them is strong and still very
much there
but it's worth noting in recent months
the former pair has been linked to other
potential Partners in July a source
confirmed to ET that Bradley was dating
Hillary Clinton's former aide Huma
abedin and Arena well she and Kanye West
had a no strings attached casual thing
last summer but an ET Source explained
at the time they were never officially a
couple
for now we're just happy to see these
two smiling co-parenting and living life
[Music]